la grande bretagne
l'eldorado des migrants ils veulent tout
seul en angleterre parce que là on veut
bosser sans papiers d'identité c'est
plus facile d'y travailler illégalement
ses croyances soient les migrants sont
alimentés par des discours politiques
comme celui de l'ancien député français
xavier bertrand pourquoi ils veulent
aller en angleterre risque et du boulot
et surtout et surtout vous pouvez bosser
là bas sans papiers d'identité alors
l'angleterre un eldorado la jungle de
calais a été démantelée il ya un an déjà
mais les associations dénombre encore
plus de 700 migrants au bord de la
manche
pourtant les contrôles aux frontières
ont été renforcés et emmanuel macron a
même obtenu une aide financière du
royaume uni les demandes d'asile sont
aujourd'hui moins nombreuses ils sont
aussi moins souvent accordé malgré cela
des centaines de migrants et c'est
encore chaque jour de traverser la
manche
pourquoi pour la communauté notamment
selon une étude récente
62% des candidats disent connaître
quelqu'un sur place la langue joue aussi
un rôle important
les migrants maîtrise généralement mieux
l'anglais l1 il pense dès lors
s'intégrer aisément et enfin et surtout
pour le travail avec un taux de 4
minutes 2%
le chômage est à son niveau le plus bas
depuis les années 70 de quoi séduire les
candidats à l'exil qui s'imaginent
pouvoir y travailler sans papiers
ym possible pour conduire un véhicule
loué un logement ou obtenir un emploi
grande bretagne il faut désormais un de
ces documents le biométrique residence
permis pour ceux qui ont obtenu un titre
de séjour ou une application registre
hishon corps destinés aux demandeurs
d'asile
ceux ci ne peuvent normalement pas
travailler mais ils peuvent obtenir une
dérogation qui doit être notifiée sur
leur carte
de plus le gouvernement a durci sa loi
immigration des employeurs britanniques
doivent non seulement exigé mais aussi
vérifier les documents
il risque jusqu'à 5 ans de prison s'ils
emploient des illégaux et ce n'est pas
qu'un effet d'annonce 2000 condamnations
ont été prononcées en 2015 donc dire que
l'on peut travailler sans papiers en
angleterre parce qu'il n'y a pas de
contrôle c'est faux
[Musique]